i have 100 minecraft players and 100
islands each player is going to be
teleported to a random island where they
have limited resources they will then
have to make tools and fight each other
to the death server teleport everyone to
their island
oh i almost fell off no everybody has
their own island and they're gonna
gather resources build bridges and fight
each other and the last man standing
between all these islands wins a ten
thousand dollar taco bell gift card oh
my god
i'm gonna try so hard for this taco bell
whoever wins will be able to eat taco
bell for free until the day they die
oh carl
wow oh he just branched over this guy
they're fighting oh chris we have a war
in our heads
chris tv they're both low on health
who's gonna win oh
he lost some materials but that's okay
chandler i made a cobblestone generator
this guy's trying to kill me carl
help
no
i hate you you die i asked you to help
me and you didn't know there's literally
nothing
chris this person's about to attack
arrow oh this guy based yeah
this guy's got a sniper nest and he's
spongebob with the cheeseburger as a
head i don't know if that's gonna win
late game i've never gone this far i'm
gonna be honest oh [ __ ] oh sticky keys
we've got action going on over here
jimmy the water bucket that's
intimidation
oh oh oh oh oh
big brain is huge oh bigger brain
[Music]
it's all a guy
oh my gosh all right he got the dub good
job good job
there's so much fighting going on
everywhere i can't even keep up with all
this excitement hello
wait how did he sprint is he hacking
what were you saying oh what's up bro
yeah
we win these we win this why is carl
screaming it looks like a lot of people
bridged over and fought carl hello carl
i can hear you screaming from the other
room what happened i got two kills so
far and i avenged chandler's death oh
chandler died yeah he's gone carl might
actually win he's good at minecraft now
where's my revive chandler buddy what
happened
come on come on come on
no i understand oh this person's getting
ambushed oh he got ambushed he's safe
though oh no he's not safe from death oh
no that was the kid who won earlier wait
what happened what he said we both died
he hit the guy off and then he said i'm
not done with you and went down with him
that guy now has three properties almost
every base on the map is interconnected
now that's wild oh look at this guy's
sky basically yeah no chris look at this
guy right here he's got it figured out
he's above the rest just mining away
don't take my stuff let my tree grow
i'll let your tree grow of course the
only thing i wanted oh we have a battle
coming up crimson turn around you idiot
yo crimson doesn't even see it oh my god
he doesn't even see it oh my gosh
oh oh dude's headphones so you hear
something oh my gosh it looks like a war
zone down here what's this guy looking
at me for chandler they're battling
they're battling oh they both suck yes
oh i have to get that supplies i have to
go for it jimmy come look at this guy
right now
[Laughter]
that skin is hilarious bro i'm gonna
connect our island let's see what
happens are they friends chris i think
they made friends you can't be friends
in a battle royale it's like when two
puppies meet for the first time they're
just like is this okay i just want
everyone to get along i just want to
farm let me be pleased you know what it
ain't much but it's honest work
i'm insane i'm so good at video games
spongebob's on the offensive spongebob's
on the offensive weaponized spongebob
are these three teammates oh that ain't
even right chief because those three are
teaming i gotta give spongebob a sword
oh
spongebob spongebob did he just eat
spongebob i laid a block he just jumped
he goes bye
for spongebob carl's lava and on this
guy i'm going for him i'm hunting this
guy i don't even care get him carl carl
we see you're fighting someone show us
your skill the world is watching carl
he's coming up what are you going to do
i'm going to get him i'm going to get
him right here ready
carl carl
oh oh all right one day one more to go
are you an animal
well there you got it there he is
oh those
carl calm down he's dead i'm insane
that's all i need
just a few buckets of lava there's a
bunch of loot down there carl
oh
my god carl you want to flex on us some
more finesse hey carl 28 players remain
28 carl you're gonna win this i really
think i can oh carl he's over carl he's
on you
let's see let's see it
oh you're done carl
carl
oh my god
i have
i have a strat now i have a strat okay
axes have more knockback so i have to
switch taxes only now that a lot of
people have died it's time for the
borders to shrink close the outside
islands out servers war is breaking out
what is going on
clash your dasher the guy who killed
spongebob just died one two survived
this guy could have just played farming
simulator i mean he might be might win
just no one's over what if the last
person falls off and this guy's just
down here farming bro watch out watch
out another guy from your right
oh oh
did i just got hit from two different
directions get wrecked were there two
people at the same time literally i said
carl to your right and you just didn't
turn
this dude's over here just still
generating cobble from his spawn do you
see he's still been on this island the
entire game let's see if he goes for
this i'm gonna put iron right here look
at his face he looks so shocked at the
idea of it
oh oh we got some contact coming there's
about to be three people fighting right
here jimmy hurry look he's building a
structure right now so that way he can't
get lava done oh this kid's good oh he
blocked himself in yep your lava's not
doing nothing but giving him new buckets
bro 15 players remain the border is
shrinking things are getting intense
they're getting pretty hot i guess you
could say mario's fighting oh we got two
people right here mario so i'm cute
oh he got him hey slime cube slime cube
can you hear me yeah i can hear you only
10 other people stand between you and a
10 dollar taco bell gift card didn't
know it was a taco bell gift card watch
out there's lava okay don't pay
attention to jimmy don't pay attention
to jimmy oh look at that
[Applause]
oh there's water there's water there's
water there's water just catch it he
missed it he missed it oh i thought he
hit it rest in peace
me jimmy distracted him imagine losing
because
jimmy wanted to talk to you i didn't
make him lose dude he's literally looked
up and then proceeded to lay two blocks
into the lava he looked up at dude you
almost clutched it with the lot of the
water though that was so close i was so
close there's eight other people
standing between you and a ten thousand
dollar taco bell gift card why i want
taco bell whatever you do cherry make
sure you win so you can eat free food
till the day you die okay yeah it would
work oh mario goes in
oh you got it mario wins let's go gosh
people are dropping holy crap ambush
ambush oh oh mario no there's no green
pipe to save him
six players remain and bitter has the
high ground he's doing the obi-wan i got
the high ground arnie we got some
tension right here so we got pewdiepie
hiding oh pewdiepie just lit himself on
fire i got that on camera oh
oh fight fight
fight fight
fight fight fight oh
oh my god that wasn't even much of a
fight he like five-headed him pewdiepie
is gonna get caught in the zone where's
pewdiepie he's right here he's right
here
[Music]
here here i'll help him i'll help him
this guy better start building up bitter
limey just gets to coast at the top oh
oh an ambush cobble's about to get
ambushed oh he saw it he saw it
oh big brain play he just got rid of the
water oh no even bigger brain all right
he laid another water oh my gosh the
strats are out of this world oh he got
rid of it again he's gonna have to build
back up cabo should have blocked that
water off oh
dude this lava hold on he got he got on
the ground pews is just staring at signs
pete says not a care in the world what
does it say i need blocks please
oh it's happening the war no
all that work for nothing four remain oh
and now oh oh gobble didn't notice oh my
gosh oh my gosh oh my gosh what a
maneuver oh my gosh if pewdiepie knew
how to play video games they would know
that kabul only had five health oh oh oh
oh oh go go for the kill going for the
kill oh nice go in he's low i don't
think pewdiepie knows how to really play
pvp pewdiepie pewdiepie oh pewdiepie is
running
oh
pewdiepie died oh wow now there's a
giant cobble tower because somebody
poured water all over the lava now we
can dig down yeah that's smart we have
bitter at the top we have bacon here and
then we have cobble three players for me
kabul doesn't know it right now but he's
got the best position so far
oh there you go oh
oh
no did he get him did he get him oh he
caught him water he caught water he
landed in water and now he continues his
conquest he's going for better the three
remaining players have all been added to
the call yo the man up there what are
you doing he's raining lava yeah he's
been doing it for the past 20 minutes
bitter do you even have a mic oh i
didn't know he's muted bitter you've
been ruthlessly just dumping lava on
them you know i would be more aggressive
if i didn't have a fractured list wow
he's saying he's gonna beat you guys
with a fractured risk it's not even a
challenge i just hear excuses so when i
beat him he's gonna be like oh it's my
fractured wrist oh
we've got competition i love it i also i
don't know if i told everyone this but
the winner gets a ten thousand dollar
talk about gift card and bitter you
maybe you could trade that in for a
microphone whether you win or not we're
giving you a new mic bidder are you
actually that'd be amazing
yes oh wait oh my gosh guys guys a fight
broke out oh sorry we were talking about
bitters mic wait cobble just killed
bacon cobble that was so mean man also
why didn't either of you say anything
and now it is kabul 7144 versus bitter
can you come down here
oh my gosh the big brain oh he's getting
honked up by the lava oh and now he's
depos
oh my god what a beauty just get out of
there while you can no way
oh my god
that was the coolest thing i've seen in
my life yeah that was big brain 500 iq
play
the brick of safety safety brick
safe bricks oh wait oh safety brick
didn't work did you just burp i died i
was about to say it as it happened well
with the death of kabul that means
bitter is the last man standing
congratulations
you now have free taco bell until the
day you die you know what i've never had
taco bell before you'll have enough to
never want to eat it again wow
cobble we're going to give you a
constellation prize we're going to give
you a 500 taco bell gift card for coming
in second
thank you
i'd also like to make it clear this
video is not sponsored by taco bell i
just thought it'd be funny goodbye